laura ingram this is the ingram angle
from washington tonight now we called
out that gutsy gal hillary clinton last
week on the show
and she apparently took time out of her
busy schedule to respond to moi on
twitter i'm going to have a response of
my own in moments but first the big
green fizzle that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
all right it turns out that today's
democrat party it's not just radicalized
it's also wildly stupid and impractical
they downplay
even denied the impact of climate change
as communities are literally on fire
we made the largest investment to combat
the climate crisis in history and
deliver on environmental justice for
people everywhere
okay her pant suit is figuratively on
fire she fibs so much all right because
when kama on the left invoke
environmental justice watch your wallet
and be prepared for a more miserable
life for you and your family what they
plan to do is to take more of what you
earned and give it to others namely
their connected friends and their
political donors it's sort of like a
reverse robin hood situation what it
doesn't mean is that your life is going
to improve or that you're going to have
more money in your pocket
we already know that they want to ban
cars they want to ban natural gas
hookups in your home they want to ban
leaf blowers ranching beef grass lawns
but ditching oil and gas in rapid
transition is just going to require
inflation stoking spending and multiples
of what they've already ran through now
courtesy of influential liberal
columnist ezra klein we have the zany
blueprint for how they hope to radically
change the way you and your family live
the decarbonization strategy he wrote in
the new york times at its core is simply
this right now sixty percent of
electricity comes from fossil fuels we
need to rebuild our electrical grid
around clean sources and then we need to
triple or quadruple the total amount of
electricity we generate an almost
unimaginably large buildup of wind and
solar power he's right about that it's
unimaginable let alone obscenely
expensive
and how much of the american landscape
pray tell will be eaten up by this
so-called clean revolution
he writes to put some numbers to that a
plausible path to decarbonization
modeled by researchers at princeton sees
wind and solar using or visually
affecting up to 590 000 square
kilometers which is roughly equal to the
land mass of connecticut my home state
illinois indiana kentucky massachusetts
ohio rhode island and tennessee put
together
you know i was thinking about that that
is going to look gorgeous just beautiful
the environmentalists apparently they
don't care about how any of their
structures will impact birds and other
fauna and flora
sorry bambi good luck nibbling on those
solar panels
they're also banking at a huge amount of
corporate welfare to force this scheme
on americans
and the bipartisan infrastructure bill
is there they're trying to sort of
wander around with checks with tax
rebates with tax credits and say if you
can create enough of this chain here
like we will give you a tremendous
amount of you know subsidies or will be
guaranteed purchasers or whatever it
might be so they're basically just
trying to spend their way to a very very
very large decarbonization
the grainiacs are trying to appeal to
biden's ego or maybe jills at this point
if biden succeeds his legacy will be
atypically physical electric vehicle
charging stations battery manufacturing
plants vast areas of land covered in
wind turbines and solar panels
all those states i rattled off those are
all going to be wind and so
now none of this is going to work as
planned i don't think any of it's going
to happen at least most of it won't they
neither have the competence nor the
money nor the political support to upend
american society this way
you want to know what the brutal truth
is here it is
the so-called utopia that klein and
others fantasize about will reduce the
mobility and standard of living for all
but the wealthiest of americans
because remember the rules they never
apply to the wealthy people they're
going to fly overhead in their
helicopters while the rest of you are
desperately trying to find charging
stations
today's democrats never think through
the consequences of their nut bag
policies never
as we saw during the covid situation
governors like michigan's gretchen
witless whitmer and california's gavin
newsom bowed down to the teachers unions
they locked those kids out of the
schools
and now
we're seeing the academic and mental
health ruin that this selfishness caused
but at least this angelic woman is happy
where's the education pieces here
where's the education pieces here
climate change if we actually stop
these extreme weather events
she's an extreme weather event that's
terrifying i hadn't seen that before
all right for a year they waved off all
the concerns about inflation these
smarty pants they went full speed ahead
with their spend a paloozas and now now
with prices skyrocketing for everything
biden wants you to think that the high
prices you're paying are just kind of
imaginary
the american people should have
confidence that we're on the right track
we're seeing real progress we've worked
to make sure our economy recovers
to lower costs for families
first has the man not seen the right
track wrong tax numbers yet i mean it's
horrible
second as for those lower costs for
american families perhaps he missed this
aside from hunter who can't i guess he
can sell those blow paint artwork things
for hundreds of thousands of dollars
most americans are really really hurting
joe
and biden's cabinet well it's teaming as
we know with far left half widths and
america has spent over 40 billion
dollars in ukraine but biden he wants to
spend 11.7 billion dollars more have you
heard that
and this this is secretary of energy's
take away from that
it has been a horrible year in terms of
the war and in terms of eyes open about
how vulnerable we all are when we don't
create our own homegrown energy sources
but that is an accelerant as well toward
the ultimate goal of getting um getting
to 100 percent clean electricity or net
zero by 2050.
now wait a second
we're vulnerable precisely because her
party sabotaged our homegrown energy all
of it was energy independence
and now a proxy war is a welcome
accelerant is that what she said to
force change on our country
if biden could have found anyone who
knows less about energy like i don't
know who would that would have been i
think listening to grand home
oh wait i found him
we need to move in the direction of
electric vehicles but we've got to make
sure that this happens quickly enough to
help us be climate change one problem
petey
mining minerals for evs is impossible to
meet demand thanks in part from the
greeniac regulations
of course they're all frauds these
people they're claiming to love clean
energy as they refuse to green light
more nuclear plants
california's energy crisis we're seeing
unfold before our eyes was predictable
especially when they shut a nuclear
plant
the green warriors and the bind
administrations
are they're about to run into the buzz
saw of the american electorate in
november
voters can see what's in store down the
road if the enviro extremists have their
way they have to look no further than
europe where things are getting
very very unpleasant
and maybe very stinky as the eu is now
poised to restrict showers
to five minutes
never forget skyrocketing energy costs
for americans
is the policy of democrats it's not an
accident
democrats must inflict pain and
inconvenience on you in order to get you
to agree to change and obey
you will love the green nirvana that
awaits you will love it
yeah some elderly americans living alone
are probably going to freeze this winter
but at least bill gates and greta
thundberg will be more hopeful about the
planet
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else